It's everything is ours.
We don't have cell coverage is grounded
into a double play that set this up.
I told him it was a family discussion.
I don't think you should sell it all.
I'm telling you.
I expect you to get so upset about.
I am upset about it.
One thing I think film can do really
well better than any other medium is
capture the reality of conversations in
a book.
No matter how you lay it out,
one piece of dialogue always has to
follow another.
You can't simulate people talking over
each other,
which is what we all do a lot of the
time and you can't really capture the
rhythm,
speed and tone that a conversation has.
Even radio and theater miss some of the
nuances that film is perfectly suited to
reproduce.
Told us he was in the hospital this
morning via text.
They were saying we want to information
of all the filmmakers working right now.
I think Noah bombeck maybe has the best
ear for dialogue as it really is an an
eras what it takes because there's a
general disconnect between what we all
sound like and what movie and TV
character sound like,
especially the most articulate ones.
You asked me that question and then my
world came apart and she came here and I
landed in the tabloids and I got death
threats and my job is constantly in
jeopardy and you ruined my life again.
Just that of course you don't have to
aim at realistic speech.
Screenwriters like Aaron Sorkin and
Quintin Tarantino have done really great
work by writing human dialogue as it
could be,
finding music and language the same way
that Shakespeare did centuries ago,
but bomb back.
On the other hand,
it seems to be committed to a different
principal.
You know,
I think I mentioned to you,
I left the company.
I was with him in a couple of other
people,
started our own firm.
It was scary in a big change,
but things have settled and we're doing
really well.
Maureen is talking to a friend about
getting someone to come up and review
the show for in recent years have
essentially been ignored.
Some of the back on the map is our logo
because $35 for a steak.
I think a conversation like this speaks
volumes in one sense.
Just by looking at it,
you can see that this is a total failure
of communication between father and son.
The two men are on parallel tracks.
Matt is talking about his new business
and Harold is talking about his
forthcoming art retrospective,
but in another sense what makes this
exchange so heartbreaking and true to
life,
at least for me,
is that they really are communicating
with each other just not explicitly.
Matt brings up a major life change and
expresses some of the hopes and fears he
has about it,
and his father immediately brings up his
own major life event and some of the
hopes and fears he has about that.
Implicitly,
Matt is asking for approval.
He's asking for reassurance and he's
asking for constellation.
Harold,
on the other hand,
is denying approval because he bear his
son being more successful than he is
while asking for reassurance of his own
hopes and constellation for his own
fears and it's like the two men are
firing a volley of missiles at each
other.
Some are hitting,
some are missing,
and some are crashing into each other in
mid air.
I think bombeck understands a key
dynamic in conversations,
especially conversations with family.
When we speak to others,
we're often speaking to ourselves
attempting to frame dialogue so that the
person we're talking to will reflect
back the things that we want to believe
about us.
When I was younger,
I was so invested in his grievances is
anger the world.
They were mine too,
but now that I live 3000 miles away and
have my own kid thriving business,
I don't even get angry at him anymore.
It's even just funny.
I'm sure a lot of people who just went
home for Thanksgiving experienced
something like this.
You feel that you've changed,
that you have an updated nuanced idea of
yourself and you're going to show that
idea in one way or another to your
family
how much money I make you make me feel
like a piece of shit because you don't
care about it,
but to also actually do really obsessed
with it.
You know that I beat you.
The thing
we seem to forget is that as we're
trying to get our family to affirm our
sense of self are doing the same thing
to us and the result is often conflict
or a conversation that just goes nowhere
or maybe not nowhere.
Just not where you intended.
That says you started your own company.
Yeah,
a couple of other guys and you just tell
you boss like I want to start with.
I was one of the partners so I didn't
have a boss.
I understand.
So you got a better offer?
No,
there were no offers.
That's what was so scary.
We were creating our own opportunity
because you wanted something smaller,
bigger.
This is my favorite scene in the movie.
It's a minute and 32nd long take of two
half brothers attempting to connect by
making it one take.
You get all the elements of conversation
that I spoke about before,
including the body language,
the projected self confidence of matt
and the nervous,
insecure energy of Danny always nodding
his head like his father.
They're doing this thing where they
agree.
Well also disagreeing.
It's a specific kind of non argument
that tells you a lot about their
personalities and their relationship.
Many of the firms clients came with us,
which was surprising.
No,
we expect it.
We can't legally ask clients to come
with us.
They don't have much choice.
It's totally their choice.
No,
I know because you have their money.
Okay.
There's so much going on here on one
level of Danny is trying to connect with
matt by literally trying to finish his
sentences.
He was also trying to challenge him and
assert some dominance by acting like he
knows what Matt's going to say.
Next,
talk about speaking to yourself.
Danny is effectively trying to hijack
matt sentences and make them his own and
listen for this.
The next time you're in a conversation,
people do this all the time.
Well,
their monies with the firm that their
money is in investments.
I bought Ptolemy lives across the street
and I lived across the street.
Dad told me about your.
Karen is like,
you can arbitrage.
Yeah.
That's not what I do at this point,
Matt and Danny or getting sick,
which actually makes it appropriate that
Danny brings up arbitrage and investment
term for when the same asset is worth
different values in different places and
you exploit that price difference for
profit.
Exploiting differences in value is a
pretty good definition of what it's like
to be in a dysfunctional family or a
dysfunctional conversation for them
matter.
It's all him.
He said that the system is rigged from
the inside.
That's not entirely true.
Oh,
mostly so this is an exciting time.
Boy.
Good.
Victoria and I are having some problems.
I never met her.
Karen and I separated.
I know.
I just said I was sorry.
Did you?
I'm sorry to and there it is.
A moment of connection.
One Minute and 13 seconds into the
conversation in the Meyerowitz family,
moments of connection are few and far
between,
so when they happen,
they land with a special poignancy and
know this family has perhaps more
intense,
more insecure than most.
I hope there's something that rings so
true about this to me when we talk so
often,
we fly around each other,
working at our own shit,
thinking about ourselves.
We try to make our meaning clear,
but we can't quite say what we want,
how we want,
when we want.
That's because communication isn't easy.
Sometimes movies make it seem like it
is,
but Noah Baumbach isn't interested in
that kind of dialogue.
He uses the medium best suited for
depicting conversations to show us the
truth about that,
that we miss the mark more often than
hit it and that it's a beautiful,
meaningful thing when we do what.
One of the questions I get asked the
most by far is what kind of software do
I use to make these videos to edit?
I use final cut pro 10 and since 10 is
so different from the programs that came
before it.
I actually depended a lot on online
videos to teach me the new features and
these days you can pretty much teach
yourself anything this way and
skillshare is the perfect way to do it.
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
16,000
classes in graphic design,
animation,
web development,
video game design,
and more.
All the classes are professional and
understandable and follow a clear
learning curve.
A premium membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to all the
courses,
but the first 500 people to sign up
using the first link in the description,
we'll get a two month free trial in
those two months.
You could easily learn the skills you
need to start a new hobby or business.
Specialized skills like learning after
effects,
which I've always wanted to do and
skillshare has dozens of classes that'll
help you master that program.
What's the skill that you've been
putting off learning?
Why not sign up to skill?
Share it using the link below and start
learning right away.
You got nothing to lose and a valuable
skill to gate.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.